for the relatives of the missing and the
surfside building collapse the weight
is taking its toll yesterday it was just
so surreal you know all this energy
of this acceptance and denial acceptance
and loss
but i know that in my heart most
probably
in heaven now with little news to give
local leaders offer
sympathy the pain in their face
their expressions it's not unlike
anything i've seen before
it is it is very difficult
to know that your loved one can still be
alive
and have the hope to believe that
and at the same time
just sit there and wait for that
information to get to you
a bus takes anxious family members from
a reunification center where sadly too
few have been reunited to the pile of
twisted steel
and crumbled concrete rescuers have made
progress searching through the massive
mound that was once
a home to hundreds but the news on
survivors is grim
the number of people accounted for now
stands at 136
with 150 unaccounted for
the number of confirmed deaths is 11.
family members have been delivering
flowers to this memorial
beneath the building where their
relatives live flowers they would much
rather
be delivering to their family members in
person
but for now until that's possible if
ever
they leave their tributes here the
search is also taking its toll on rescue
workers
and the family members watching them
they witnessed a rescuer tumbled 25 feet
down the mountain that is a perfect
example of the situation that we're
dealing with
they search by digging trenches into the
rubble using sonar
camera robots and dogs like oreo
some aid in the rescue others serve as
therapy dogs
but there is little comfort for the
families of the missing so we have
official word we're still trying to hold
on to whatever hope remains
but realistically we we know that
they're gone with each day that hope and
the prospect of finding survivors
grows more elusive john hendren al
jazeera
surfside florida